[Musique]
Christian Dufour bonsoir bonsoir c'est
sorti en dernier heure hier Jean Charest
qui a gagné son procès contre le
gouvernement du Québec on se souvient je
le contexte j'ai offert entendre je vais
inverser la en haut je vous faire
entendre d'abord jean-charrell en
janvier 2020 l'entrevue que j'avais fait
avec lui quand il quand il disait qu'il
n'allait pas participer à la course
conservatrice le l'autre pas celle-ci et
je lui avais parlé du pack des
accusations etc et voici ce qu'il nous
disait
c'est c'est dans le domaine public tout
ça vous allez vous le savez s'il y a eu
un coulage toute ma vie privée a été
répandu dans le domaine public parce
qu'il y a eu un coulage de l'UPAC ils
sont sous enquête pour ça c'est connu
depuis très longtemps
alors il était furieux bon c'est très
long se passagerait il était furieux etc
réaction aujourd'hui je vous donne la
parole après est-ce que le gouvernement
du Québec doit s'excuser ou pas là ils
doivent payer 380000 mais doivent-ils
s'excuser monsieur Legault il est
l'opposition qu'on revient
sous la gestion de monsieur lafranière
qui était choisi par le gouvernement
libéral donc la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir est-ce que
moi je dois faire des excuses ou non du
gouvernement libéral qui a nommé
monsieur la Fragnière
j'exclut pas ça mais on voit analyser ça
comme
ce qui a été commis les fuites en lui à
la justice et ça c'est criminel alors
s'il y a des accusations à porter
j'espère qu'elle le seront et que les
bandits vont finir en prison du reste
toutes ces fuites là auront nuit à la
marque libérale c'est très clair c'est
pas ça qu'on voulait pensez-vous qu'on a
créé l'UPAC en SD on va créer l'UPAC
pour faire un chèque de 400 000 agents
charrette non quand on a créé le pack on
voulait faire un chèque au Québécois
québécoises pour les rembourser de cette
fête à voir par un système de corruption
pendant des années au Québec je pense
que si ça fonctionnait je pense qu'on se
poserait pas de questions mais là de
considérer de réintégrer à la sortie du
Québec je pense que c'est souhaitable
le juge allait qui est très dur dans sa
décision en disant que c'est fuite là on
nuire fortement monsieur Charret que les
on rappelle la base dans une démocratie
une enquête policière ne doit pas être
public tant qu'il y a pas d'accusation à
l'aigle
oui c'était à peu près n'importe qui
d'autre que Jean Cherel les taux
québécois ce serait déjà excusé
probablement mais comme politiquement
Jean Charest n'a pas une très bonne
réputation dans l'opinion publique on
n'avait pas envie de s'excuser de passer
à autre chose parce que ça aurait très
mal paru alors on s'est dit on va aller
jusqu'au bout de cette cause là en
sachant très bien qu'on allait
probablement la perdre du côté des
procureurs du gouvernement du Québec je
dirais ça prenait quand même pas la
science infuse pour voir que 54 fuites
différentes sur Jean Cheret avec lui à
sa réputation mais comme c'était Jean
Charret les scandales la corruption
l'odeur lorsqu'il était au pouvoir la
carte du ben nous on s'excuse pas parce
que ça va très mal paraître
politiquement puis on va aller jusqu'au
bout des choses ça va coûter 385 000
dollars à l'État québécois et quand
François Legault dit je ne sais pas si
moi je dois m'excuser pour quelque chose
les libéraux ont fait mais c'est pas à
lui en fait de s'excuser c'est à l'État
québécois et il incarne les tocs pas le
chef de la CAQ donc s'il y a pas le
choix il va s'excuser aujourd'hui notre
politique là-dedans mais éventuellement
devra peut-être s'excuser au nom de
l'État évidemment c'est pas lui
personnellement qu'on va demander de
s'excuser un peu vous dites de l'ajout
de politique l'État québécois doit
peut-être des excuses en tout cas ils
doivent faire un chèque en attendant
parce que Monsieur Charret haute
parenthèse je vous donne la parole
Christian et Véronique monsieur charère
avait toujours dit
c'est le prix d'un timbre le règlement
de cette histoire-là s'il veut s'excuser
qui fasse une lettre il l'envoie puis je
retire ma poursuite Christian
moi je trouve honteux ce qu'on a fait
monsieur Charret je sais que Monsieur
Charrin n'est pas populaire que beaucoup
de Québécois qui aiment pas les
politiciens qui sont les beaux
émissaires de leurs malheur que des gens
qui se réveillent la nuit pour haïr les
libéraux mais ce sont des êtres humains
et moi je trouve que Monsieur Lego doit
s'excuser au nom de l'État québécois il
nous représente c'est pas son
gouvernement qui a fait ça c'est pas lui
qui a fait ça mais c'est pas ça le point
c'est le pack du pack ne s'organisation
de public qui relève de l'État québécois
le jugement est dévastateur je pense
qu'il faut le rappeler c'est pas mineur
là parce que Monsieur Charest a subi
donc la première réaction de monsieur
Legault ce matin me demande plus déçu là
mais là je pense qu'il s'élève comme le
dialecte il faut qu'il s'excuse on n'est
pas une tribu les Québécois là on a un
état on a un Premier ministre qui
représente l'état un peu de place
monsieur le groupe excusez vous je pense
que c'est dur monsieur Charest ça fait
je sais que c'est difficile de défendre
comme le dialecte monsieur Charrin est
un des gens qui le détestent mais un
être humain pendant 10 ans on a essayé
de trouver des choses contre lui ça rien
donné sauteuse que fait monsieur Lego
s'excuse moi c'est clair et Véronique
au-delà du fait bien sûr que c'est un
être humain mais c'est un citoyen d'un
état et que les enquêtes policières
fassent des premières pages et plusieurs
c'est un abus de pouvoir un peu parce
que si on se met à rendre le public les
enquêtes policières sur pierre
Jean-Jacques il y a des gens qu'on
voudra défendre d'autres qu'on n'aime
pas qu'on voudra pas défendre mais les
citoyens doivent être égaux devant tout
ça Véronique absolument puis j'ai
l'impression que Monsieur le goût est un
peu déchiré en justement
est-ce que c'est l'ajout de partisane
c'était pas des amis là j'enchain
qui s'entendaient même au niveau de la
personnalité je parle pas juste au
niveau de la couleur politique mais
vraiment même au niveau de la
personnalité mais d'un autre côté en
étant Premier ministre lui-même François
Legault a quand même une certaine
empathie par rapport à la fonction ce
que Monsieur Charret a subi au niveau de
sa réputation clients auprès de sa
famille aussi les impacts sur le parti
politique alors je pense que monsieur
Legault est probablement le mieux placé
pour comprendre ce que ça peut avoir
comme impact justement dans la vie d'une
personne comme ça de haut niveau là qui
a été premier ministre d'un autre côté
rappelez-vous ce que Frédéric Gaudreault
comme ça du pack avait fait pour Guy
Wallet c'était lui que c'était excusé
qui avait fait des excuses publiques
donc ce qu'on était en train de
réfléchir à cette possibilité là de dire
à ce que c'est l'UPAC qui doit s'excuser
ou c'est réellement le Premier ministre
le goût
pourrait dire Véronique que vous dites à
l'UPAC excusez vous donc ça va éviter
parce que le juge aussi va plus loin et
dire monsieur Charest si vous voulez
même poursuivre avec vous pouvez
continuer puis on verra jusqu'où ça nous
mène
ouais mais je pense pas que Jean cheri a
besoin d'argent ancien premier ministre
du Québec qui fait de l'argent dans le
privé depuis des années pension du
gouvernement fédéral ce qui est pour les
politiciens très difficiles c'est
lorsque le réputation est entachée
lorsque le Rego est écorché c'est les
bêtes d'ego les politiciens ils veulent
pas on se lance en politique parce qu'on
a quand même assez haute opinion de
soi-même on pense qu'on peut changer les
choses qu'on peut contribuer à la vie
publique donc lui les dernières années
les a vécu très difficilement Jean
Charret depuis maintenant toutes ces
fuites à l'UPAC donc lui c'est pour ça
qu'il dit excusez vous qu'on va régler
ça c'est pas de temps l'argent qui est
assez pour lui symbolique même si ça
reste une somme considérable mais lui
c'est certainement les excuses qu'il
souhaite parce qu'il va pouvoir
continuer à poursuivre moi je pense que
s'il y a une forme de de mea culpa que
ce soit du pack que ce soit de l'État
probablement qu'on va en rester là je
suis pas jean-charl mais je pense que
c'est davantage ceux qui souhaitent
c'est une énorme victoire pour Jean
Charret puis les principes enjeux sont
fondamentaux c'est pour ça que moi
j'espère très sincèrement que Monsieur
Lego va s'excuser mais on a classe de
s'excuser ce serait très décevant
j'ajouterai juste c'est aussi oui je
voulais juste ajouter aussi que
n'importe quel premier ministre veut
laisser son lait puis je pense vraiment
pas que Monsieur charrette dans les
livres d'histoire vu qu'on retienne ça
donc c'est sûr que lui son objectif
principal c'est cette réhabilitation là
puis en même temps au gouvernement le
goût je pense qu'il comprenne cette
portion là aussi là
voilà c'est
Louise Arbour qui nous disait dans une
entrevue ça m'a frappé ce qu'il a amené
à une carrière de droit c'était la crise
d'Octobre 70
l'abus de pouvoir un état 64 pire c'est
s'il faut se garder de ça mettre des
murailles des contrepoids etc et voici
un bel exemple ou l'État ne peut pas
laisser les policiers salir quelqu'un à
moins de l'accuser c'est accusez vous
taisez-vous Christian quand vous dites
les principes fondamentaux c'est ça dont
on parle dans une démocratie
en même temps concret et je le rappelle
ce qui est policiers sont populaires
mais c'est des êtres humains aussi parce
que Monsieur charrette vécu pendant 10
ans mettez-vous à sa place à la place de
sa famille ça joue ça aussi
troisième lien c'est rendu que c'est
devenu une chronique presque quotidienne
troisième lien monsieur Legault qui
répondait à une question à l'Assemblée
nationale on l'écoute on revient
et en début d'année
la vice-première a reçu des études mais
qui reflétaient pas suffisamment les
impacts du télétravail après la pandémie
parce que il y a encore des impacts
importants donc on vient elle vient de
recevoir ses études ont été en train de
les examiner les analyser je demande au
chef de la deuxième opposition d'être un
peu patient si quelques semaines tout ça
va être dévoilé
ça avance ça avance et je vous
demanderai pas ce que vous y croyez
encore parce qu'on donne déjà fait ça
plusieurs fois mais monsieur Legault en
tout cas continue à avancer hier
monsieur Legault et Monsieur Trudeau on
en parlait lors de la devise
monsieur Legault monsieur Trudeau a dit
mais s'il y a un projet de transport en
commun on va étudier ça avec plaisir
tout sourire Véronique donc là d'ici
quelques semaines on va présenter
quelque chose
enfin on apprend que les études sont là
hier elles étaient pas là puis peut-être
qu'elles sont arrivées pendant la nuit
mais aujourd'hui Monsieur le goût
confirme effectivement qui les a entre
les mains moi je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de remarquer qu'à chaque fois qu'il
parle du troisième lien François Legault
va parler aussi de la pandémie des
impacts par exemple au niveau du
télétravail alors j'ai l'impression
qu'il parle à deux clientèles différents
une clientèle qui veut vraiment pas du
troisième lien alors c'est comme si le
diminue le projet l'ampleur du projet en
disant vous savez la pandémie
télétravail ça a changé la donne c'est
plus nécessairement les mêmes
statistiques de circulation puis l'autre
clientèle on dirait qu'il diminue les
attentes celles qui veut avoir le
troisième lien c'est comme oui vous avez
peut-être n'avoir un peu le projet qu'on
a annoncé au départ mais d'un autre côté
il y a des impératifs qu'il doit prendre
en considération notamment le
financement du gouvernement fédéral qui
de 40% c'est pas négligeable quand même
du gouvernement fédéral a dit nous on
finance pas des projets autoroutiers si
les projets de transport collectif donc
la nouvelle mouture il y aurait deux
tubes dont un de transport collectif
strictement alors là ça leur permettrait
vraiment d'aller chercher
qui lui veut des voitures donc il y aura
un tunnel avec des voitures le meilleur
marchand qui a toujours pas donné son
appui mais lui va un tramway plus on
n'exclut pas d'avoir une ligne de
tramway dans la portion de transport
collectif alors c'est comme si le projet
est en train d'évoluer ce sera plus la
même version encore le faire mais pour
quand puis on essaie de plaire à tout le
monde là ce qui est des fois parfois
difficile Alec
ouais j'ai hâte de voir comment on va
réconcilier la baisse d'achalandage
télétravail avec un tube sur deux pour
le transport en commun parce que si les
gens travaillent la maison ils prennent
pas plus le transport en commun que leur
voiture alors j'ai hâte de voir comment
vérifier à faire la quadrature du cirque
quand ça va être rendu public moi je
pense que c'est essentiellement une
question de financement Véronique a
raison moi ça fait longtemps que je
pense que ce qui risque de faire déraper
ce projet-là ce sont les coûts parce que
non seulement dans la région de Québec
il y a des sceptique mais même ceux qui
aiment le troisième loin le troisième
lien sont généralement des conservateurs
fiscaux des conservateurs économiques
ils vont peut-être trouver que ça a
quand même pas de bon sens de dépenser 6
7 8 milliards pour un tunnel alors il
faut faire baisser la facture à Québec
je pense que c'est ce qu'on cherche à
faire puis si on peut en envoyer 40% ou
50%
Ottawa parce qu'on a même temps
davantage de transport en commun c'est
davantage ça qu'on cherche à faire alors
on verra bien jusqu'à quand même c'est
le même père de taxes là c'est pas les
martiens qui payent Ottawa là ce sont
nos
vous avez raison ok Christian
je pense que pour Monsieur Lego une
promesse électorale c'est quand même
important puis avant d'y renoncer c'est
difficile pour lui bah moi ce que je
sens mais ça vaut ce que ça vaut c'est
qui branle dans le manche en fait quand
il nous dit d'après ce qu'on comprend
les études démontent que la baisse de la
chaîne en d'âge durant la pandémie bah
ça semble maintenir malgré la fin de la
pandémie et et aussi pour mettre en
œuvre un tel méga projet il me semble
qu'il faut avoir une énergie on va
renier là moi je trouve que cette
énergie et c'était là et plus là
d'accord donc monsieur le Gaume semble
un peu enlisé
qui est très importante qui est très
complexe mais moi je suis pas rirai pas
là dessus très simple que c'est
tellement gros qu'il faudrait que plus
je comprends ce que vous Denis marcelet
au revoir est-ce que c'était un très
très rapidement à vous trois Véronique
je pense avec vous est-ce que c'était
inévitable grand patron de la SAC quand
j'ai du mal absolument à la mi-mars
qu'en François Legault a fait une
conférence de presse dans laquelle il le
dit on va évaluer le travail du PDG du
conseil d'administration à ce moment-là
je me suis dit son heure a sonné c'est
une question de temps parce qu'ils sont
tellement insatisfaits de la
planification le problème c'est pas les
bugs informatiques c'est vraiment la
planification le fait qu'il y a des fils
de personne
mais en fait je donne pas mon opinion je
vous dis juste que c'est écrit
on voulait que quelqu'un paye pour le
fiasco on dit souvent au Québec personne
est imputable des erreurs puis tout le
monde garde sa job on voulait que
quelqu'un perde sa job le PDG celui le
responsable ultime de ce qui s'est passé
il y a payé Christian
c'est très très important et puis on a
eu tendance à abandonner ça ces
dernières années et c'est au dos en plus
remarquable que le monsieur en question
c'est un haut fonctionnaire qui a fait
une belle carrière je sais pas je suis à
quel point il paye pour les autres mais
c'est son imputabilité au moins il y a
quelqu'un qui est responsable de ce
fiasco là et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
merci beaucoup à vous trois moi je vous
dis au revoir je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine merci bonne soirée
avec de l'électricité si possible merci
au revoir au revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI